meet aaron and abby
they're craniopagus twins which means
they're joined together by the head
these surgeons successfully separated
them
so how do they do it
one of the biggest challenges with
separating conjoined twins when they're
conjoined at the head is making sure
that each brain has sufficient blood
supply to it and sufficient drainage
away from the brain and that really
becomes in some ways the whole shooting
match
i'm dr jesse taylor and i'm the chief of
plastic surgery at the children's
hospital of philadelphia i'm gregory
hoyer i'm a pediatric neurosurgeon at
the children's hospital of philadelphia
we're going to walk you through the
tools we use to separate conjoined twins
[Music]
abby and aaron are connected like no
other twins i think one of the hidden
innovations in the approach we took was
rather than just figure out how to
separate them how do we change how
they're connected how do we help
ourselves before we do the actual
separation one of the things we we're
trying to do is use what we call the
biological matrix to gradually pull the
twins apart using force instead of just
chopping them apart which is a grotesque
way of saying what surgeons have done
for over 50 years
the biological matrix is how cells blood
vessels and tissues work together to
heal the body after an injury using this
principle along with these four tools
allowed surgeons to separate abby and
aaron
this is a model of the first ct scan
that we got of the girls as they were
conjoined and what it showed us is that
they were connected by bone and then the
covering of the brain obviously they
were missing twice as much
skin and subcutaneous tissue as would be
on the top of your head the second thing
about the models were we could turn them
and look at where those veins came in
to the head one of the major challenges
of the surgery was how we were going to
handle a big vein in the head called the
superior sagittal sinus and that's a
vein that runs down the center of your
head and most of the blood that goes to
your brain runs through that sagittal
sinus and into a part called the
transverse sinus right sort of where if
you are wearing a ball cap where that
ball cap would rest in the back if you
lose your vein in your arm your arm
might swell it'll likely have another
way for the blood to come back from your
arm in the brain because we're talking
about a closed structure if the blood
isn't able to come back from the brain
you'll have a stroke before the twins
were separated the team used distraction
osteogenesis to further push apart the
twins at their connection
two unique things about distraction one
is by slowly pulling bone apart the body
lays down bone in between so it actually
is a form of tissue engineering of bone
second interesting thing about
distraction is the side effect of bony
distraction is changing the shape of the
soft tissues brain blood vessels dura
skin at the same time that you're
changing the shape or configuration of
the bone we got together with the
engineers from depuy cynthia's which is
a subsidiary of johnson johnson in
design these modified helmets that fit
on the tops of each of the two kids
heads and then in between the two
modified helmets were a series of three
machine screws that were about a half
inch thick the device itself the helmets
plus the screws weighed maybe two pounds
and there was a step before we placed
the halo devices on them so we created a
soft channel all the way around them to
give those devices a bit of a mechanical
advantage although we're using things
that we normally do in the or and sort
of adapting and changing them this is a
product that only fit these twins and so
it went back and forth until we could
see what was working and ultimately the
pressure that the screw was placing on
the skulls to pull the skulls apart
exceeded the perfusion pressure of the
skin which led to skin ulcers we
ultimately abandoned the distraction
device
[Music]
after that we went to a custom it really
looks very similar to a hose clamp and
what a hose clamp is is a band that's
got notches so that as you turn a screw
on the band it decreases the
circumference of the band itself and
that was made out of a very inelastic
rubber so that there was a bit of give
but not much the distractors were on for
about five weeks and then the
contraction device was on for about four
weeks
the detractor pulled the twins apart by
25 millimeters or about an inch and the
band further constricted their shared
space by about 30 millimeters this
realigned the twins and help decrease
the complexity of the surgery
navigation system is something we use
routinely for brain tumors and for
people who aren't doing brain surgeon
which i guess is most people in the
world what navigation is an analogous to
the gps in your car that gps isn't the
exact location of your car is but it
shows you on a map where your car it's a
representation and what that allows is
we're then able to put a pointer and i
can see on the screen which will be
right next to me where we are in the
brain so that we get some level of
safety as to where we are so it never is
a stop see where we are it's a constant
reassurance during the operation process
so when we started the operation the
twins were laying on their sides in one
direction and we opened that side and we
started to dissect through the brain on
that side when we got to the place where
we thought we were about halfway through
we then flipped the twins onto the
opposite side and began operating from
that opposite side so the surgical
navigation as we would point the wand
would confirm to us that yes we're
headed towards
that cleavage point that we had already
opened on the other side so that was
another way that it it just allowed us
to kind of confirm that we were going in
the direction we wanted to go
in 2017 the twins were successfully
separated after 11 hours in surgery
abby and aaron were the third set of
conjoined twins that dr taylor and dr
hoyer have separated so if i had a wish
it would be that we could start our
process of changing the connection
between the twins in utero where there's
immensely more plasticity to the brain
and the soft tissues if you could sneak
into the womb with some endoscopes
and put a rubber band in between the
area of connection
and that rubber band had just enough
force to not exceed the perfusion
pressure of the tissues
but at the same time begin to constrict
that connectivity to me that something
like that is going to be the ultimate
answer to this problem the morbidity
from doing the surgery the way it's
currently done
it really is massive
if i take one step back we're in front
of the camera right now we're the ones
talking about their separation there was
an army of people so an anesthesia team
a great rehab team a great nursing team
ultimately what we're trying to do isn't
necessarily innovate in surgery it's to
do better for our patients but not for
innovation's sake we're doing innovation
to make kids do better so it all comes
back to a quote of our boss dr adzic if
you save a child you save a lifetime and
so if you can't get geeked up over
fixing
uh newborn babies and having them doing
better after your surgery then then
you're in the wrong business
[Music]
you